Oooookaaaaayyyyy!
Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Subnautica!
I just got the materials necessary to be able to build the Cyclops,
minus an Advanced Wiring Kit
I might even need two, I'm not 100% sure about that.
How many did I neeed?
Question? Question? I need one. Okay.
So I've got every other ingredient besides that one.
The only problem
Is to make an Advanced Wiring Kit I need two gold,
and a computer chip which needs table coral, silver, and quartz.
Now that's not entirely hard,
but I forget if I can get gold around here.
I forget if it's JUST silver
or maybe it's GOLD, so....
Either way I've got to go find some silver
but I'm pretty sure I'll be able to find some gold
Somewhere....?
MAYBE?!
If if nothing else, I'll be able to go down into the purple
area and be able to get that.
So I'm very close.
So what I'm gonna do, is I'm just gonna get
Oh! I fucking forgot!
I fucking forgot I don't have a knife anymore because it fucking brrr-oke.
So I need to make a Kniiiife.
Fffuck. How do you make silicone again?
GOD
Fucking Dammit. (rip Mark)
Okay. I've got the necessary materials
to make a knife
so now that I have a knife I'm going to be able to *darkiplier* STAAAB
my enemies in the eyes (⊙ヮ⊙)
and also be able to do what I need to do
to be able to get what I need to get.
So, once I do that, I'm going to get the table coral
and I'm gonna go down into the purple area
and get the *mark voice* all that I need
and gonna be able to do *mark voice* what I need to do.
[British accent] When will I be able to make a modified version of the knife again?
I don't know!
[Normal voice again] Ok there's gold, that's good
and I don't know if it's gonna give me silver...
Okay, so I got two pieces of gold, that's
AAA! AEEE! AY! FUCKING FUCK. WHATTHEFUCK.
What the fuck dude?!
Ya wormy bastard!
At least you're not the big one!
I mean honestly though, jeez-us
I hate the ocean!
Goddammit.
Okay, so
I'm not, I'm not too scared...
that didn't get me too badly. (sure Mark)
*very quietly* It got me badly.
O-right
Brrrroop
Baaaa-roop-boo
Ooo, okay
So now that we've got this
We're gonna maaaake
I didn't get the goddamn table coral because I'm a goddamn goof!
And we should be gooooood
to go.... o-right.
Quartz?! GAHD!
I'm such an ass
Hairy ballsack!
Okay. Who bit me? Fuck! Stop.
O-right.
O-right!
Here we go
This is gonna be the one.
This is gonna be the good one.
Alright, maaake the compuuuter chip...
Baddabing baddaboom baddabing-bo...
Make.
The.
Make the Advanced Wiring Kit
Baddabing baddaboom baddaboom-bo
And that is absolutely everything that I need to be able to make
the Cyclops. So now,
all I have to do is go back
to Jeffery, Billy, Samwise, AND Marshall,
who are by the Aurora like the good li'l boys that they are
Which is still blown up, thankfully,
after I deleted the save-file, I didn't know if it was going to be like that or not
But, I go back there
I get them to build what I need
and then I have the Cyclops
I dock my Bumblebutt in my Cyclops
and then I will have everything that I need
to be able to do what I need to do
Hello~
Hi friends, how ya doin?
Oh good, it still has power
which I was very much worried about.
Heeey.
Be nice. Be kind, rewind.
Okay, so I should have
I'm not 100 percent sure but
Whoa. Fucking goddamn it, they're so speedy now.
Those sand-sharks, they're speedier than the goddamn
like stalkers. Holy shit!
Need to cool it.
Alright.
But
We have what we need
and that is very important, so
if we get back on, woah
wew, weahw, woaw
Alright, Jeffery, Billy, Samwise, and Marshall!
Are you ready to GET IT ON?!
Are you ready to BUILD SOMETHING?
BIG!
Cyclops.
Oh I wanna mention, also,
uh, I have extra titanium ingots
I went all out, I farmed as much
as much titanium as I could
and put them into titanium ingots
because I know that I'm gonna need plasteel
ingots to be able to make
um,
the Pressure Compensator Increasors
which is also usable on the Prawn,
it's usable on the Seamoth,
or the Prawn.
but ALSO
If you wanna get the Reinforcements Module for the Cyclops
you're going to need
one helluvalot of plasteel ingots.
and you have to make the Pressure Compensator first anyway,
and I have aluminum oxide crystals
um... back...
Where do I have them?
I might even have the Cyclops Pressure Compensator that I picked up somewhere
but I'm not 100% sure. But you need that
So, with further ad(o)-eh-
Here comes THE CYCLOPS, baby!
Build it!
Make Daddy proud! <3
Oh! You're such good workers!!!
Oh, you're such good laborers!
And I know that can't be easy to make
but I'm really proud of you guys for doing that. <3
So with this,
I don't think they've made any improvements to the Cyclops
not that it needed any.
The Cyclops was already a very capable ship.
And here it COMES
HAAAA-- aw shit, ooh
AAAH!
OOOHHHH.
It's listing.
OHHH NO...
I mighta goofed a bit
Maybe I shoulda turned... JEFFERY, BILLY, SAMWISE AND MARSHALL?!
What have I told you about looking around before you build random giant bullshit?!
Oh, goddamit.
Alright, hang on.
[Cyclops starts speaking]
"Welcome aboard Captain", I know!
I'm gonna open these storage-
[computer voice finishes speaking]
Oh, I miss that voice.
[mimicking Cyclops] "All systems online."
Hap-- okay, good, alright, there we go, fuck.
Alright, uhh
I forget about the cam- okay there we go rear camera
Alright, is the ass-end out of the way here?
Good.
Fucking carved a piece of the Aurora out of there
but at least I've got that. Okay.
So now, we've got our dude and we need to name him.
Submarine name is gonna be:
I'm gonna name it, I know what I'm gonna name, I'm gonna name it
Big. Box. Barry.
BIG BOX BARRY IS COMING ALONG SIDE TINY BOX TIM
which, I might name, I might rename my Seamoth "Tiny Box Tim".
But I oh ah
I'm named this Big Box Barry
Because Big Box Barry
is gonna come down and fuck up the entirety
of the ocean down below.
And, I'm hoping,
that we're going to have a wonderful color-scheme for this..
What should we do?
Something noticeable?
Oh, it should definitely be the big daddy,
to, uh, the Seamoth
so definitely should be
it should be... A giant BUMBLEBEE!
It should be a bumblebee!
Oh, it's gonna look so GOOOOOD!
Oh that's so cute, Big Box Barry!
Alright, I'm gonna need to make the name, uh,
in black, but that looks fucking good!
Oh that looks good. Did they make it bigger?
I don't know if they made it bigger or not.
Either way, thank you, Jeffery, Billy, Samwise, and Marshall! <3
You stay here, you hold down the fort!
You hold down the fort, and maybe I'll come back if you're good.
Alright, lemme just see if I've got anything useful in here
Huddeleduh... Nothing in there...
Aluminum oxide crystals! I do need that.
I can make another plasteel ingot if I've got lithium
which is right THERE
So if I make a plasteel ingot then I should be able to make a Pressure Compensator.
And then...
That will be one step on the way to being able
to make what I need to make.
So, I can grind this stuff down
Ah, shit, lemme just do this real quick
I've got 8 titanium ingots
one plasteel, which I'm gonna make the Pressure Compensator out of
if I don't have it here
Which I'm beginning to think that I do NOOTTT.
But I've got what I need there
and one aluminum oxide crystal, one plasteel
and I should be okay on that front.
Let me just take this extra lithium just so
I don't have to look up more of it.
But I've got THAT.
I've got what I need I don't think I stored anything
back here, did I?
Okay, so I think I have everything that I'm gonna need
There.
Ooh, hey, wew, weeww, wo okay.
So let's dock
Bumblebutt in Big Box Barry.
And we should be A-Okay.
Yes, pleeease.
Oh, yes.
Oh, YES!!!
OH! YES!
I miss that. Oh, I miss that a whole lot.
So now I should be able to put
the Power Efficiency Module
[reading] "recycles heat byproduct to increase engine efficiency".
That's one upgrade.
Power efficiency now 400%.
So I'll be able to recycle a lot of power.
Climb up the other siiide...
Got a lot of Power Cells, all good in that neighborhood.
So, we're all good there.
So now comes the JOB of PILOTING
BIG BOX BARRY
back
home
under
the sea.
And that takes a long while to do
So either way, enough stalling, I gotta get this thing back
and on the way I'm gonna get as much salvage
as possible to get more titanium
and just basically, load this bad boy up
and maybe even before that I'm gonna try to make
a Fabricator INSIDE this Cyclops
so I can get what I need to get
to be able to build
what I need to build
to make this thing go even deeper than ever before.
But first stop is obviously getting all the titanium
salvage that I possibly can.
And I know I'm skipping over some of it
but I just kinda wanna pilot it because I haven't had the chance in a while.
YAY!
[weird voice] Mah "Beg Bawks Barreh" is a commin' fer yew...
Okay, so Locker One.
And, unfortunately, you can't change the names
of the lockers on here,
but I'm pretty sure you can BUILD things in here?
And I'm pretty sure... yeah!
You're able to build things in here.
So, once I get some more quartz
I should be able to make...
[talking to self] what? why do I need? why can I build that?
Oh that's right, I can just place them down
on there, I just can't build them yet.
But I should be able to build
uh, lockers, down here, that I will be able to
put the names on. So I'm gonna do that
in just a second, but I wanna store all
of my GOODIES...
I'm gonna put all of my titanium ingots in there because
if I fill all that out I'm gonna have everything that I need.
I should have all the titanium ingots that I need.
I'm gonna put the lithium THERE
Put that there...
I'm just gonna try to get oodles and oodles
and scadoodles of titanium
'cuz that's what I neeed
...And carry on from there.
[singing] LU LU LULU LU LULU LU LU LU!
Getting materials is lots of fuuuuun!
Did I... empty the shit out of this dude?
Did I do that? Lemme check.
Yep, I did, okay so yepparooni, this is the welder
don't need that, I need the repair tool.
[singing] Shoobideboop Shoop Beeboo Shibibboop Shooboobiboo
Boo Diddi Deedoo Shibop Shoobebop
Shibobbity Bop, Deebowbow [singing ends]
And I'm good to go!
Let's go get what we need.
Okay, I'm full up
Gawd, that thing is bigger than I remember it being
Hoooly shit, okay
Scoop me up baby! Scoop me up BIG BOX BARRY!
Sorry, guess I bonked into you, didn't mean to.
[computer speaks] "All sytems online".
Are they? It would be concerning if they were not.
I've got a bunch of materials, I'm pretty much loaded up
I need to somehow get shit out of there
but I'll worry about that later.
I gotta DROP OFF...
So, you get: bleh, bleh. bleh...
And you get: bleh, bleh.
And then you get: bleh, and then...
Aaahhh-I will keep this.
But, I can make THESE now!
She-boo-de-boo-boop debuhbuhboo
Can I make them stack two-high?
If I plan this out accordingly, I think I can make this two-high...
Okay, YES! I can make this two-high!
I can have SO MUCH storage!
Oh, this is going to be good.
Oh this is gonna be "hella" good.
Stahp. Okay!
So first up is "charlietiberius2" who said:
"Markiplier you should really try to tame the stalkers, it's cool,
"I tamed one, swam with it, scanned it,
and even wound up dropping a tooth from eating the Peeper."
"Not sure how long it stays tamed but I hung by it so
I would see if it would attack me and it didn't".
So, in the last episode I definitely did tame them
and I meant to read this in the last one but I kinda
skipped over it, I forgot about it.
But thank you so much.
It didn't really benefit me but I ended up getting enough Stalker Teeth because
they stopped trying to eat me
so that was good advice.
And next up is "mondan33" who said:
"You can distract the Warper by placing down infected fauna-
You know, the fish with the green blotches?"
"Any creature that's infected with the Carar bacteria
is a target for the Warper."
And this is another interesting thing that I wanted to see
I'm gonna take off my gloves
and look at my hands
Now, they don't look like they're green and infected just yet
but, then again, I'm not 100% sure
if I'm completely clean.
but it seems like I'm doing relatively okay, I just don't know how well that's gonna do, also
I need to make the still suit, that's uh- that's another thing.
And lastly uh, there's "arcreation1"
who said: "I understand the pain
"of living in the Grand Reef, I put my base
"right at the entrance of the cave to the Lost River
"and I'm constantly in need to make runs
"to the safe shallows for titanium
"and other stuff, also only surviving
"on simple things like bio-reactor
"and fruits and veggies. Life sucks."
Indeed it does
but, it's useful
or atleast that's what I keep telling myself
I think it's useful, but it probably isn't
because there's multiple entrances into the Inactive Lava Zone.
However, I will persevere, I will press on
because I believe in myself and I know-
that I can do what I need to do.
So, I've got a bunch of storage-
I've got a bunch of shIiAaite
and I've got a bunch of what I need to be able to make what I need to make.
But I need to get..to my uhh- little old seapod, over there
to be able do the last few steps here.
So I need to make runs over there
and I will do that in just a jiffy~
But not before I navigate these horrible horrible turns and twists
yeeh..
Oh boy, I'm- I'm dragging aren't I?
I'm dragging aren't I?
I shouldn't have come to the safe shallows
with my bigass submarine..
Ah, fuck.
Big Box Barry stop smashing up against everything-
Well I made a goof
I made a couple of goofs on my way over here.
Get out of my way!
Get out of the way!
MOVe! Move!
Ok-
WTF, what was that? Jesus.
Am I leaking?
Go the long way around
and comin' in for cruis- ooH shit
ANNNND
LIKE
AAA
GLOOVE-
and, I think we -GOT IT!
Nailed it! Got it good!
I did that PERFECTLY
Ok, so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna load up on the stuff that I put in storage
boode-de-boop
Don't know why I did this, when I was just gonna go craft em'
M'kay, now I'm gonna craft up all the titanium that I got
and hopefully get the resources necessary to be able to make
a fabricator inside my Cyclops.
Inside Big Box Barry.
So, hopefully- I have all the materials necessary
because I got a lot of silver- I just
I got a lot of table coral-
I'm not 100% sure, EXACTLY what you need but I think I'm pretty close
and then I should be able to have a mobile fabricator
to come with me, whenever I need it
and then, I'll have everything I need.
To be able do, WHATEVER it is I want to do.
Whatever that may be, I don't know!
But I've got it!
So that's good.
bubba-da-boop
Alright I can't be too wild about this
so I gotta make what I need to make first
so let's seeee, to make a fabricator you need a wiring kit and a computer chip.
To make a wiring kit, you need silver ore-
I should have 3..
I do have 3, I have 3 silver ore.
I planned this out VERY well.
Wiring kit AND a computer chip.
I should have both the necessary materials, and then I should be able to make A FABRICATOR
INSIDE my Cyclops!
and then I have, what I need
to go WHEREVER I wanna go.
I have no limits anymore. The WORLD is my oyster!
AND MAYBE
FINALLy
I'll feel fricken safe in the FRICKEN Ocean
Middle fingers out rockin', pointed towards everywhere who wants to kill me..
*Deep Inhale*
and I'll be good.
Once and for all.
Computer chip, wiring kit, should have everything I need-
mmn- Did I need titanium? That's a good question, did I need that?
I don't rememberrr.
I did. ahahah- Fuck.
Alright, ok, so I'm not gonna be-
I'm not gonna egotistical and put a fabricator up here,
I'm gonna be PRATICAL, and put a fabricator down here.
Where it's actually legitimately needed.
And I'm gonna do iiieieeet riiight on the inside of this door,
because that would be smeaart.
And if there's one thing Markiplier is, it's smAeart.
HABOOSKI!
YYYYES!!
And I can make Cyclops pressure compensator,
I've got a plasteel ingot right here, AND an aluminum-oxide crystal
which I will be able to use to make a pressure compensator, RIGHT there.
Doesn't even have any sort of a, model or anything like that.
Doesn't even need one
Hey baby <3 How ya doin'?
And then I'll be able to go up here- allelololalala
BAM!
la la la BOM BA!
Shove that in, BAM!
Crush depth now 900 meters, it's exactly the same as my Prawn suit.
I'm able to go down exactly the same distance
AND thusly, I have the necessary item to be able to be made the ULTRA Cyclops Reinforcement Module.
All I need is 10 plasteel ingots and another aluminum-oxide crystal,
of which I have both.
Wait, do I? Hang on. Let's just- let's just
Let's just double check here.
Wait (x8)
Let's just double check here, I've got doot doot doot..doot
Yes! I've got 12-
titanium ingots
and then, all I need after that is lithium
and I've got 5, I would just need 5 more lithium.
Which I can defiantly find, and then an aluminum-oxide crystal
which I'm sure I have back at my base.
So I AM sitting VERY, pretty.
And so I'm gonna go on my way back to my other base,
down in the depths..of Hell.
But before I do that I'm gonna farm a bit more, but I will do that in-between the next episode.
And this one.
So, THANK YOU! Everybody so much for watching
I accomplished a lot in this episode and I'm very proud of what I've done here.
and mah big baby, the Big Box Barry
so thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know how I'm doing down in the comments below
and if you want your name on a locker inside my brand new Big Box Barry just let me know
So thanks again everybody for watching
and as always, I will see you
In the next video!
BUHBYE!
*Outro music* (captions by amylia :D, hi every1 :DD)